hello and welcome
back to this webinar for bioinformatics
and infectious disease research so we're
going to be starting in just a couple of
minutes here
hello and welcome to this webinar on
bioinformatics
for infectious diseases we're going to
be recording this webinar
we're also going to be sharing it on
social media so
please be mindful of that
hello and welcome to bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
we hope that in this program in this
session
you will learn a little bit about
bioinformatics and how it's used to
study and characterize different types
of infectious diseases
and i hope that after this webinar you
will be
also you will be familiar with some of
the ways that bioinformatics is used
in covid19 research as well as the
design and development of novel
antiviral drugs and vaccines
we'll give you a little bit of a
perspective on how such
data is being used and how you yourself
can potentially use genomic data to
to apply to different types of
infectious pathogens
so after this webinar is over you're
also welcome to
explore our upcoming program
called bioinformatics for infectious
diseases it's a training program
that will allow you to be effective at
using
some of the types of tools that we'll be
discussing
today and hopefully you'll get a good
sense of what that will look like
so in this uh upcoming program
in a second sorry
so today we'll talk about how the
emergence and development of
bioinformatics
in different types of tools for
infectious disease research
can be used to characterize
infection from different types of data
perspectives
and we'll also present several use cases
for bioinformatics analysis methods that
are used in pathogen diagnostics
viral evolutionary studies antiviral
drug discovery
vaccine design as well as the
characterization of for emerging drug
resistance
and to showcase uh some of these ideas
and some of these types of
uh projects we'll actually use uh the t
bioinfo analytical platform then we'll
talk a little bit about
several sections specifically designed
for such studies that were
made available as a user-friendly
interface that you can also try
so we'll talk a little bit about what
the infectious diseases are
how can we characterize and study them
from a genomic perspective
what are some of the tools methods and
data sets that are available
and then we'll talk about this upcoming
program that will allow you to
learn how to use these tools effectively
i do want to mention that a lot of the
materials that we'll be discussing
today have been designed and developed
by a team of researchers and a team of
bioinformaticians that work
at pine biotech but also at the
university of haifa in israel
in the tower excuse me at the top of
bioinformatics research center
so these include the lead scientists
that have
participated in research together with
other prominent labs around the world
and we will also talk about some of the
examples briefly
that have come out of those studies a
lot of the methods and tools
as well as the resources that we will
discuss in the context of the upcoming
bioinformatics for infectious disease
research
program will also be incorporated and
those have been designed
uh as uh by our team
of mentors including uh julia panov
and so even though i will be speaking i
will be presenting
different types of analyses and content
that will be presented in that program
and this was a
team effort for all of us so let's uh
start by talking a little bit about what
infection
is um and so infectious disease
um is the infection the result of
infection it's the invasion of an
organism's body tissues by
disease-causing agents
so it's their multiplication and the
reaction of the host tissues to the
infectious
agents and the toxins that they produce
so an infection disease also known as a
transmissible disease or communicable
disease
is an illness resulting from an
infection
infections are caused by infectious
agents called pathogens and they include
viruses and related agents such as
periods
viroids bacteria fungi parasites
and those parasites could include
unicellular organisms like malaria
and macroparasites like worms so
non-infectious diseases
as compared to infectious diseases are
also recognized as
chronic and can be caused by such
factors as environment
nutrition and lifestyle as well as
genetic inheritance
the world health organization recognizes
four main types of chronic and
non-infectious diseases
and those include cancer cardiovascular
diseases
chronic respiratory diseases like asthma
or chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
and diabetes now as you will see a lot
of these are actually
not so clearly separated a lot of them
have to do with each other for example
chronic diseases might be a risk
for infectious diseases and infection
can
cause development of chronic diseases
as we know about cancer autoimmune
diseases and many others
so in fact the separation between these
two types of diseases
is not very clear there's a lot of
overlap and there's also a lot of
different types of cause and effect
type of associations between these
different conditions
the replication of pathogens in the host
leads to major types of interference and
this starts from
membrane disruption as in the case with
viruses
and the release of toxins as in the case
of many
bacterial pathogens many of these
interferences
induce molecular biological pathways
designed to fend off intruders
and signal to neighboring cells of the
upcoming danger these pathogens
can also modulate the pathways and cause
long-term organ damage such as lung
tissue
scarring due to the immune hyperactivity
so in fact
the same pathways that were designed to
prevent and stop
this kind of infection can also
lead to major types of effects later on
now the hosts can fight infection
using their immune system so here uh we
have a few examples
uh of how that happens mammalian hosts
react to infection with an innate
response
often involving inflammation followed by
an adaptive response
vaccines are used to train the immune
system and to identify pathogens and
store the necessary epitopes for
antibody production
in the long term immune memory but due
to a variety of factors such immune
responses can actually be insufficient
on their own
so two main approaches that have
significantly reduced
death from infectious diseases in the
past century
are antibiotics antiviral drugs
and vaccines vaccines have been
discovered first as far
back as the early 1800s and are becoming
major
have become major instruments to train
the human immune system in response to
various pathogens
reducing worldwide deaths significantly
in the 20th century
as a result of water treatment use of
vaccines and antibiotics
death rate from infectious diseases was
reduced over 10
fold in the 20th century but the 21st
century
came around with significant new
challenges
antibiotic resistant bacteria and the
spread of such bacteria
even in places like hospitals as well as
significant new challenges from novel
pandemic zoonotic viruses that we were
not prepared for
of course here you can see several
examples this is a brief timeline
of novel vaccine design and you can see
that
this type of an approach to vaccines
have has led
a lot of people to think that we are
done with infectious diseases in the
20th century and then the 21st century
came around
and of course such new challenges like
swine flu
birds flu ebola virus and coca-19
have really shown how unprepared we are
for these viruses that are
emerging and causing pandemics
over here you can see how significantly
the reduction of death rate has been as
a result of different health
epidemiological measures such as
use of chlorine and water in the united
states
use of penicillin vaccines
etc has really reduced the death rate
and of course here you can see the
opposite picture what happened
in uh 2020 as here you can see the
comparison of
the rate of death from covet 19 to 2017
death rates from other types of
conditions
for example drugs and alcohol
diabetes lung and tracheal bronchus
cancers and pulmonary disease so you can
see that covid19
is actually a higher uh the death rate
from copenhagen has been
uh going up and we know that this is the
story is not over it continues
and so we'll see how bioinformatics
can help in some of these challenges
thankfully at the same time that the
pathogens were studied under the
microscope
humans also started developing
sequencing technologies that could help
decipher the human genome
and as a result such detailed and rich
molecular data has transformed our
understanding of infectious diseases and
pathogens themselves
in the last 20 years availability of
genomic data has lab
has led to an increasing understanding
of how cells function
at the molecular level and has allowed
us to understand major causes of deadly
diseases
with the current rise in viral outbreaks
and their deadliness there's a major
focus on developing tools
and data repositories for a much better
understanding of the emergence
prevention and treatment of infectious
diseases
as a result the major advances in data
generation
analysis methods and the utilization of
insights from such studies
is making a completely new approach to
diagnostics
disease characterization and the
development of novel
interventions to such pathogens what you
can see here
is the way that sequencing is used to
study pathogens
we know that we can now assemble genomes
and accurately compare them between
each other to understand how they are
interrelated
and also develop genetic markers so that
we can understand
what are the drivers of virulence and
spread
and how they can be helpful in
diagnosing and detecting early
indications that there's resistance to
drugs and of course one of the major
uh capabilities of sequencing is that
this is digital data it's easy to store
manage
and analyze and so as a result there are
many
public databases and data sets that
allow us to ask
very detailed and specific questions
about some of these pathogens
now as a result of this capability of
genomic sequences
we can now understand and study
population structure and evolutionary
history we can also identify the
specific
sequences and very specifically identify
the cause of different types of
outbreaks we can
have insights into how to make such
technology to identify the specific
strains
early on and hopefully take early on
measures for that
and then also we can use some of the
downstream analysis results to
inform drug design and vaccine design as
can be shown here and this is taken from
new england journal of medicine so
genomics and bioinformatics have
contributed
immensely to our understanding of
infectious diseases and we can actually
apply
sequencing data to study disease
pathogenesis or how these pathogens
cause disease we can study mechanisms of
interaction
between proteins of viral and bacterial
pathogens
and host pathogens or in the their hosts
we can also study the spread of
antimicrobial
drug resistance and even the host immune
response in a very detailed way
so the result of these bioinformatics
tools and the sequencing methods is also
has led to the emergence of genomic
medicine that has substantially advanced
our ability to
detect study and treat infectious
diseases so one of the
major impacts of genomic medicine has
been on
infectious diseases over the years so as
a result
the ability to perform such
bioinformatics analysis
leverage some of these tools and access
these large
data sets is critical for all those of
us that are
participating in such research
onyx data is now regularly used to study
viral genomes dna
variation host gene expression protein
abundance
and composition properties of microbial
communities
and all these are very different types
of data that all together
form a comprehensive holistic picture of
how these pathogens
interact with the host cause disease but
also
live in communities that we need to
learn how to study
and understand so what we'll do today is
we'll take a look at several examples
of how such data could be analyzed and
what type of information such data can
provide us with
so the role of bioinformatics in general
in the context of infectious diseases
will allow us to study such data to
extract important information and so
what kind of
information can we actually extract we
can talk about the association
of viral genomics and evolution placing
that in the context of time
and geolocation so we can ask questions
about
where did a specific pathogen originate
how does it
spread in the population what are some
of the different phenotypes that it
produces
in the population we can talk about
immune response
and really define how immune response
is changing in the course of disease
progression
and ask questions about what are those
specific
phenotypes caused by which genes and may
be identifying molecular pathways that
we can interfere with
leading us to novel drug design and
combinations of drugs that could be
effective at suppressing
disease manifestation as well as
addressing the specific pathogens so how
do we
interfere with the pathogen production
colonization
and the production of toxins and also it
allows us to understand better
the conditions in which these pathogens
thrive and how to interfere so for
example
a large component of the immune response
is that initial microbiome composition
so we can ask questions about how does
that composition change
what are some of the factors that affect
the changes
and how we can be more informed about
the approaches to intervene
and to preserve a healthy component of
this immune system or the immune
response in the microbiome
so one major way that bioinformatics is
actually
changing our understanding of the
microbial world
is the ability to ask very basic
questions about individual organisms
their functionality
environment and the communities that
they form
and in fact this new sequencing
technology and the methods
have allowed us to not only look at
individual
pathogens but also study these
communities as a whole
and so a little bit of what we will
touch upon is the diversity
of viruses and bacteria as well as their
interaction with the microbiome
and the viral that could be studied as
a single community instead of just
individual pathogens that we
identify so what is the virum the virum
is one part of the microbiome
which constitutes all of the organisms
that inhabit us including bacterial and
or kale
organisms as well as the microbiome and
other members of the mayo fauna
such as protists and metazones studies
of the biorum are actually in their
infancy because it has only recently
become possible to see
and study the viron in large sequence
data sets using bioinformatic tools that
can detect relationships between viruses
despite their extreme nucleotide
sequence diversity
and dynamics because they evolve and
rapidly change
the size of the mammalian environment is
actually not known
or and we think that there is a
tremendous diversity
and it still has to be studied further
to really understand how diverse it is
and it is continually updated through
rapid evolution of viruses
and to exposure to viruses in the
environment or in other mammals
so it's a fairly complex picture to or a
puzzle that has to be assembled together
before we can ask specific questions but
what
already is uh clear from the ability to
analyze sequences
are some questions about the very basics
or even
life itself so biologists have
categorized life
into three large domains bacteria
archaea
and eukarya and
we know that viruses were originally not
even considered
in this tree of life but these novel
abilities to compare
sequences and identify genes that are
responsible for specific type of
functionality
have really opened our research to
understand
viruses as potentially participants in
the dynamics
and the diversity of life itself
and we can think of them as agents of
change
because they have to be able to
replicate themselves using the cell
their host cell machinery
and as a result there's a lot of
exchange of genetic material that
happens between viruses
and their hosts that include bacteria
as well as eukarya and archaea and so
as a result we see this exchange of
genetic material
between these different hosts and we
now can think of viruses also as maybe
potentially a uh part of this tree of
life in general
so before we continue and we'll talk
specifically about some of
the tools and methods that could be used
to analyze such data
let me pause here for a second and ask
first of all if you have any questions
before we continue but also let me ask
you a couple of questions as well
so i know that there's a lot of people
here some of them are online
on youtube and some of you are online on
zoom
uh so if you're on zoom i would like to
ask uh
if you could put down in the chat box uh
where are you from
and what institution are you uh in
working in studying in
so um really where are you located
uh geographically and what institution
are you in
uh so if you could use the chat box uh
and just
let us know and that would be great just
so that
we have some sense of where you are
right now
all right thank you dr duma i see that
you're from
ethiopia and please don't forget to
mention what institution you are part of
again gamma sciences and technology
university
uh and i see uh
southeastern louisiana university thank
you caitlyn
sheffield university the neuroscience
department
uh thank you
kenya ke mri
i thank you miss shock nairobi kenya
great
all right well um applied biology
department thank you
osmania university india kenya medical
research institute
african university of abu may khalabi
benin all right excellent so thank you
for sharing this information this is
going to be useful for us
as we plan these workshops for the
future uh
so again uh for anyone that is joining
us
uh we welcome you from all these
locations and it's great to have you
with us
today um so what will um
okay thank you and uh we have somebody
also here from lagos nigeria
uh so um it would be great to continue
and stay in touch
and uh to really um benefit from
uh some of these future webinars uh and
some of the
resources that we provide what we ask
you
um to do if you would like to continue
and
participate in some of these in the
future is join
our social media groups um so that we
can stay in touch so we have a group on
linkedin where we discuss
a lot of the emerging topics but also
have posts about different research
opportunities
as well as career opportunities so if
you are interested in bioinformatics and
comics data
please join our community on linkedin as
well as
on facebook and we um
we can continue and share some of these
updates there
okay so uh let's go on uh we'll um
talk next about next generation
sequencing and really
how can next generation sequencing data
help us ask some of these questions uh
in
relation to infectious diseases so one
of the major
challenges in omix data is of course the
ability to
process the data and extract meaningful
information
that we can use to ask very specific
questions using
analytical tools so this challenge is to
process visualize and organize data
so that these questions could be
answered
in metagenomic and viral sequencing
there are
three types of sequencing approaches
that we're going to be talking about
today
there's what's called targeted
sequencing where we can amplify
a particular pathogen or a type
of microorganisms a specific taxonomic
classification so we can talk about
different types of
primers that allow us to sequence a very
specific
type of a genome we can also talk about
amplicon sequencing and amplicon
sequencing means
that we amplify a particular region and
this could mean that we
combine specific library preparation
techniques as well as pcr
amplification to have enough material to
study
diversity for example and then of course
we can
sequence everything and sequencing
everything can
yield all dna so all of the
genomic material or all rna material and
so when we talk about
gene expression data the response of the
host
to infection we can study that using rna
sequencing so
we'll talk about some of these different
methods importantly
a lot of this type of data is actually
organized and made available to the
general public so
here you can see an example of a couple
of different places where you can find
stitch data
the joint genome institute as well as
the ncbi
provides us a very good view of how much
data has
been available and there is a lot of
rapid
growth and accelerated increase in the
number of available
sequences now many of these data sets
are structured
in other words they are already
assembled genomes
and these assembled genomes could be
viewed by a particular name so you can
go
on this new project for example called
ncbi virus and you can actually find
specific assembled genomes or specific
sections genes and proteins of those
genomes
and there's a lot of what's called
bioprojects or
array data sets that you can actually
study for novel types of
tools that allow you to compare
different components
and sequences and gene expression data
and so
it really provides us with access to a
very diverse
set of data sets that we can use to ask
specific types of questions
uh now uh the data that we have access
to
can also provide us with rapid
identification
of novel sequences so you can see how
such
viral outbreaks measures can be studied
using next generation sequencing
for example we can take data
specifically from clinical specifics
specimens and identify either
a particular viral sequence and then
study that sequence and how it's
different from other sequences that we
already know about
or we can actually look at metagenomic
sequencing and
analyze all of the data that is
available there
potentially looking at multiple types of
viruses that are available
multiple types of pathogens that are
available and then study variation and
composition
of these communities within each sample
here you can also see some of the
additional ways that we can apply next
generation sequencing data analysis
tools
to identify detect resistance to
antimicrobial
antibiotic resistance analyze
changes in the microbiome community and
of course study the host gene expression
or
transcriptomic data now i mentioned
already that
the ability to analyze such data
is complicated by the because this data
is
unstructured so essentially it consists
of
short reads you can see here millions
and
billions in fact of reads that could be
extracted from a single sample
and one of the challenges to make sense
of what does this
make data actually mean and uh
to do that we can assemble
these short reads and analyze those
reads
linking them to functional components so
another
important repository here is the
repository of
reference sequences sequences of either
specific
organisms that we already have studied
and understand their functionality
as for example in here you can see that
one of the first steps that had to
happen
when this outbreak of this novel
coronavirus happened
is that we had to have a good reference
of this genome
so that we can map the reeds onto the
particular
genes in the genome and understand their
function to study
how does this virus actually function
inside the host
so once we have that sequence and we can
map
the reads that come from novel
sequencing samples onto the
reference genome we can in fact start
asking questions
so what kinds of questions can we ask
one question that we ask is sequence
variation
by aligning new sequences that we have
to a reference and we can ask this about
the virus we can ask this about the
bacteria we can ask about any genome
that we have
by just mapping them onto a reference or
by mapping them together to identify
similarities
between different components that we
have identified
now to ask a question about
how they are related we can also conduct
evolutionary analysis by looking at
relationships between these sequences
and
organizing them into a phylogeny or how
they are
interrelated by coming from
some common origin we can also then ask
questions about how the differences
between these genomes or genomic
elements like genes are functionally
leading to changes so here you can see
a mapping of mutations on one of the
proteins produced by a virus
and the question that we can ask well
how does that
actually affect the interaction between
this protein
and a corresponding host protein
that could mean a change in the way the
disease
happens or the way that the transmission
happens
and then we can also ask questions about
the host response and really
that is a different approach here we are
more looking at the expression at the
levels of genes
how the the host response the
expression of genes varies between
different types of infections and at
different stages of infection
causing us to understand how the immune
response varies between different cells
of course in different tissues
okay so one of the things that i would
like to introduce now is
some of these approaches on the t-biome
for platform
where we have developed easy to use
tools that you can try and use
for analysis of phylogenetic
relationships
by identifying and mapping relationships
between genomic
elements that are different between each
other
how you can study gene expression by
analyzing transcriptomic data
uh alignment of sequences to each other
to detect
prominent mutations and variations that
we can link to their function
functional changes um how such data
could be
taken to the structure to understand the
relationship between sequence
and structure and how variant calling
and identification of particular markers
of
these genomic changes could help us
understand why
such structural changes are happening
so let's first talk about uh the
alignment
the process of alignment so multiple
sequence alignment
is a typical approach to identify
changes uh based on nucleotide variation
as well as based on amino acid variation
so to analyze such data we need to
uh understand the differences in
multiple
genomes and to compare those genomes
based on areas that are matching
in those sequences and importantly to
understand
the functional implications of such
changes we also need to understand the
relationship between
nucleotide sequence and amino acid
sequence so let me
give you an example i'm going to go to
the server platform so uh this is
the link and perhaps some of you that
are not joining us for the first time
might already be aware with this
platform
the platform was designed to incorporate
all of these different methods of
analysis
into a single interface and make it easy
to use for even someone that is not
that does not have a technical
background in an engineering computer
science background
so one of the ways that you can try out
some of these methods before you
actually uh
you know use this platform for research
is by requesting a free demo account and
the way you can do that is you can
go into this access tab right here and
fill out this form
and you will actually get a free demo
account that you can try out some of the
things
that we are going to be doing now so i'm
going to show you a brief example
of what this multiple sequence alignment
really looks like
so that we can then try and apply it to
an example data set
so here i'm going to go to this virus
quasi species section
and going to go into this first demo
for multiple sequence alignment
this whole area is actually designed for
multiple use cases you can see that you
can
identify point mutations in
sra files or fast q files where we are
expecting to find
a whole diverse population of let's say
viruses you can also identify function
of defective viral genomes that might
have
large long sequences deleted
from the full genome and you can also
study relationships between
the sequences that have been assembled
into haplotypes
or if you have consensus genomes you can
also understand the diversity of these
consensus genomes so a very basic
pipeline that could be made here is
based on this data set of multiple types
of coronaviruses
which include the novel source cov2
genome
the bat genome of a similar virus
and then also sars one genomes and so
the question might be how are they
different
and what do those differences mean in
terms of their amino acid substitutions
so here i'm going to just click on ok
and you can see that i have a section
here for multiple sequence alignments
i can press on multiple sequence
alignment that allows me
to understand specific similar
and different sections on the genome
converting those nucleotide sequences
into amino acid sequences which will
give us
insight into how different physical and
chemical properties of those regions are
changed
and i can then ask question well how
likely
is it for such a change to occur and
also
what kind of implications for this
substitution
will i expect to find on the functional
level
so i'm going to click ok importantly
we know that the evolution or the
accumulation of mutations
does not happen in the state at the same
rate
in different types of codons and so i
can also include
different variation to how i look at the
specific codon positions to analyze
this data and then i want to build
a phylogenetic tree that essentially
uses multiple sequence alignment
to determine relationships between
sequences
and assign time based on different
models
and you can see here a number of
different models that i could use
or i could just combine all of these
phylogeny methods together
and essentially what i will get as a
result is the
relationship between ancestors and the
present-day species
based on some assumption about how that
rate of mutation can lead to the changes
that i observe
in the samples that i have in my data
those
trees could be analyzed and i can
combine
all of the trees that i get as a result
because each different method will
produce a different result
and then select some of the most
representative trees
that i think are more linked to the
actual data that i have
based on comparison between multiple
trees
so clicking on end here will give us the
results
i can open this folder and take a look
at some of these results and
really start asking questions about what
does this
mean so let's first of all take a look
at some of these
results i have here
a ape tree which is one of the methods
and then here i have the beast
birth death process tree so we can take
a look at
what do they look like and how can this
give us insight into what these
different
types of sequences what type of
information do they contain and how are
they
organized into this relationship so here
you can see
that this phylogenetic tree a rooted
phytogenetic tree
contains one two three and four
defined groups and one of the questions
that i might
ask is how does the data that i
have about these sequences can help me
understand
what cyrus code 2 for example what is
the closest
relative for source code 2 out of all of
the sequences
that i have uploaded into this analysis
so beyond just having the ability to
look at a phylogenetic
tree or look at the sequenced variation
or maybe ask the question what is its
relationship
and how does this affect the amino acid
and the protein structure
ultimately i would like to link all of
this information together
so to do this we have actually created
a visualization tool to help
ask those specific questions so the same
tree that you are seeing right here the
same sequences that we see
there here they are in a more visual
and interactive format you can see
in this tool which we call sequence
navigator or seek nav
you can see the sequences of the genomes
and those sequences are organized by
groups
here you can see mers sars
coveted 19 or source code 2 and beta
corona viruses or
other coronaviruses that are not
sars or mers and the
cells are bins each bin represents
500 nucleotides we can make it also into
250
so let's take a look at 500 first
well okay so they're loaded uh so here
we can see that each one of these bins
represents
a bin of uh 250 nucleotides
we have the reference genome that it is
mapped to and the difference
is color coded from gray all the way to
this darker red
so right away what we can see here are
some of the groups
are different in terms of how similar
they are to the reference genome
so based on what you see and you can by
the way
navigate to this link yourself and try
it out for yourself
which which group do you think
is the most dissimilar
to this reference genome
[Music]
okay you can type your answers into the
chat box
which see which group of sequences is
the least
similar to the reference genome again
gray is the most similar
red is the most dissimilar the most
distant
based on the number of changes that are
observed in that bin
each bin is about 250 nucleotides so
which group you can see that there are
groups
mers sars covet 19 or source code 2
and beta corona viruses so which group
do you think
is the least similar to this reference
genome
okay so caitlyn is saying beta corona
viruses and
the shack is saying coven so
kate okay is also saying beta corona
viruses
so let let's see what might be
some indications for this um
as i mentioned gray
is similar right so if i look at this
whole group
it is very similar because in fact they
don't have any variation here between
gray yellow and red
and so as a result i know that this
whole group which is covered
is the most similar to the reference
genome and the reason for this
is of course because the reference
genome is
sars code 2 and so it is exactly the
same reference
genome now if i want to look at other
types of comparisons i can for example
take a look at the covet 19 human
genomic sequences
and ask the questions how do these sars
code 2 genomes differ
between themselves but in the context of
these comparisons
this group stars cove two is the most
similar to the reference genome
so the question is which type of a virus
or group of
groups of viruses are different from the
source code too
and the answer is that indeed like you
mentioned
either this group which is mers or
this group like beta coronaviruses so
beta corona viruses contain a lot of red
in specific regions right including this
region right here
and this region right here so let's now
talk about
what might this mean so i have here
sars which is source code 2 which is
very similar to sars
one and quite dissimilar with
mers and beta corona viruses
so one question i can ask well how are
they
related to each other in other words
which one is closer and which one is
farther away
and so the answer to that is this
phylogenetic tree
the phylogenetic tree tells me
which groups are closely related to each
other and which ones are farther away
from each other so here you can see
that covet 19 and sars one
are closely related and they are closer
related
to mers than they are to the beta corona
viruses
so even though just looking at the
sequence alignment i don't really know
which ones they are closer to
because there's so much variation if i
look at the phylogenetic tree
which gives a model for how
one type of a sequence could originate
from another one
i can start organizing these into
relationships
and these relationships tell me that in
fact they do
differ in in terms of how closely
related they
are to each other now the other thing
that i can ask
is how do the groups within
each defined group or each clade
relate to each other as well and i can
see that they all
do have differences as well and these
differences
are actually related to time and so i
can see that
beta corona viruses have the greatest
diversity in terms of time just because
they see that
this axis which corresponds to
evolutionary time
shows me a greater divergence between
the actual sequences
and also in this group right here which
is coveted 19
that diversity almost does not exist
which is very logical of course
because cobit 19 has been around just
for such a brief time
and this time incorporates such viruses
that have been around for years and
years
and so the diversity of the samples that
i have in the different groups
actually represents very different
physical time or real time
and therefore this evolutionary time
differs between diversity measurements
in each one of these groups
the other question that i might ask
is how the differences that i observe
at specific positions on the genomes
could be interpreted by looking at what
proteins
they encode for so here i have
this reference genome that also shows
the different proteins
and these proteins could be uh
or these genes uh and and here i can
look at these genes and what actually
they do so you can see that
one of these additional areas that have
a lot of
dissimilarity is the surface
glycoprotein or the spike
as glycoprotein so here i have
this spike glycoprotein we know that it
is responsible for
interaction with the host protein for
cell entry i can actually see this 3d
structure of this protein
and read about what it is and i actually
actually
go to this link which will take me to
the ncbi
where i can find more information about
this protein and that full sequence
so this is an important component as
well not only am i asking the question
how do these different sequences related
what
areas are mostly related or most
dissimilar but also i can ask the
question of what might be the functional
result from changes in that protein
and so as you go deeper into these
comparisons
more and more questions could be
answered by studying
the sequences inside each sequence
remember that there's
250
250 nucleotides and here if you hover
over you can see how many of those
are actually different from the
reference so you can see that this very
red one
has 220 changes from the reference
this one has 57 and of course a gray one
can have zero or a very small number
like
three so this tool allows us to
interpret some of the results from such
sequence
analysis from such a multiple sequence
alignment and phylogeny to start
understanding
what might be some differences in terms
of where these genomes originated from
and how these genomes could be
different in the way that they interact
with the host
and here since we see so many changes in
the specific
spike glycoprotein we can start asking
additional questions
about what specific changes are there
and how can they explain the differences
between
what this virus does and how does it
actually cause disease
so this is an important kind of a tool
in the toolkit that we have to compare
assembled
sequences by aligning them to each other
and understanding what types of
mutations or changes
we can observe in the sequences that we
have in our data
now importantly not all of the
changes are represented equally in the
data that we have
if we have full fast queue files and
these fast queue files
actually represent specific
sequences from reads short reads
we can see that some of the changes in
those reads could be of high confidence
for example if i have a read that i can
detect in
multiple reads and all of them agree
they give me the same result and i know
that it is a change
from the reference i will be confident
in that change but in some cases
i have a lot of variation so even though
i see a change that change is very
different inside different reads
if it is different inside different
greens i really cannot call this a
variant
and so the variation between the
different reads
in the sequences of the reference genome
have different weights
and different types of information that
they can give me
to understand how those mutations
are accumulating in the population of
viruses that i'm studying
now for this purpose it is important to
call variance and distinguish between
the different types of variation that i
have in the data
so here we have an example you can see
that this is
coverage and identification of these
specific types of positions where i have
high confidence
is also carried along with positions
that i have
low confidence and sometimes the
proportion between them
changes as well so this is an additional
piece
of information because the reality is
this typically represents
a diverse population of sequences
that accumulate as the virus replicates
inside the cell
so if i'm looking at this situation i
have a particular
original virus coming into the cell or
coming
into the host it replicates and has to
evade
multiple pressures associated with
the immune response and competition
between different
progenies of this individual virus and
as a result
a lot of mutations occur and i can
actually study the variation
of this population using some of these
mutations that accumulate in the
individual genomes
that i can sample so if i take a sample
one single sample let's say from a
patient and take another sample from a
different patient
i can actually ask the question not only
how the
genome in each one of those of a
specific pathogen
is different but i can also see what
diversity levels am i observing
and oftentimes these diversity levels
are associated
with violence and the
danger that they can carry for the
immune system
because as the virus mutates it is the
only strategy essentially that it has
to evade the detection and suppression
of what it does inside the cell and so
as it
accumulates these mutations some of
those mutations can become
more significant in other words the
virus
of with that particular mutation becomes
more abundant
and in some cases some other mutations
can become
less significant so they can really
represent some kind of a dying out
population now again to piece all of
that information together
i can also organize the relationship
between these different types of viruses
into one single tree and then i can
study these trees
to understand populations and this type
of an analysis
phylogenetic analysis can be very
powerful for me to
start associating with whatever i
observe at the phenotypic level so a
good example of that
is of course this visualization
that probably most of us are already
familiar with
that allows us to link how time
diversity in the viral population
and some phenotypic information about
the location
or maybe the number of people that were
infected
in a particular region could all be
linked together
now importantly we see that
these mutations do not accumulate
equally
in each viral genome or
in each viral gene sorry so
the prominent mutations the mutations
that start
emerging in a particular region on a
particular
time frame are important for us to study
further
now what kind of information can we
extract
from a carefully selected
number of sequences when we start
looking
at the in-depth meaning of these
mutations
let's take an example the example that
we'll look at
is the example of this
specific comparison between
changes in covid19 genome
as compared to some of the sars1 genomes
and the bat
coronavirus genome to try to ask the
question
of what might be the probable origin
and how might the virus originate
from a similar species like a bat
or a pangolin as compared to the
coronavirus that we observe in the human
and so to do that first of all an
important part of such a question
is finding the right data and typically
the
way that we can select for the right
type of data to ask such questions
is to first analyze large quantities of
data
to study variation overall and then to
reduce the number of
genomes to a very particular set of
genomes that we have high confidence
in so these could be consensus genomes
and based on that consensus genome we
can start
asking very specific questions about
individual positions
on the genome that show some major
change
that we think have a functional
implication so for example
if we start from an analysis overall
here you can see how
analysis between many genomes
could be converted into a comparison of
overall similarity across the genomic
positions
and identify very specific regions
that show high difference
now that high difference could now be
interpreted by asking very specific
questions
about the positions that are different
and the distance between the positions
what do i mean so here we have an
overall kind of an overview of how we
can take this study further for example
if i know of a particular protein just
like we saw the spike like a protein
has a lot of variation
within that sequence of that protein
let's say the spike glycoprotein is
about 1500
nucleotides long sorry
1500 amino acids long so we can
start asking the questions of how can we
identify the functional significance of
those changes so here we see
amino acid sequences that we can analyze
in terms of sequence identity how are
they
similar how which context are they
placed in
and also what types of features can we
identify
in those genomic sequences we can also
look at the 3d structure
and think about how can we position the
changes that we observe in the sequence
on this folded structure so which ones
are outside which ones are inside which
ones are interacting together which ones
are
more distant from each other and
obviously we can also
generate high throughput data that shows
us the response of the host
that could be different because specific
positions have changed
so here is an analysis of such data
for this spike like a protein and you
can see that
this is the percentage similarity
on the reference genome sorry
and you can see that the major changes
occur
in the spike protein so these major
changes across
groups of different sequences reveal
the changes that we can start looking
into
deeper and we can separate the spike
glycoprotein
into different functional domains and
these functional domains
are corresponding to the different types
of activity that this protein
actually assists with
so if we look at this receptor binding
domain the specific position
of mutations that we can see they
accumulate significantly in the receptor
binding domain
and we can link that to our
understanding of the overall
interaction between the viral proteins
and the host proteins for example
we know that it interfaces with the
human protein that sits on the membrane
right
it is a protein that is responsible for
cell entry and so we can see how the
specific
uh protein of the virus the spike
glycoprotein
interacts with the h2 which is hosted
inside this protein called b081
so the interaction between the virus and
the human cell
is first interfacing in the receptor
binding domain
and just one part of this ace
ii b081
complex now as we look into this
receptor binding domain
we can see that it is only about
200 nucleotides long and this 200
nucleotide
sequence could be studied in much
greater detail
to reveal how the particular
changes that we observe in the genome
are responsible for
adaptation because we know
that the complex that we observe here
and the specific receptor that is h2
in humans is also different between
different species
so by analyzing the genomic sequences
of the pathogen and analyzing the
genomic sequences of the host
we can start answering the question
of how a particular interaction
between different hosts can help us
trace
the evolution of the virus as it came
from
other species and eventually started
infecting the humans
now answering that question conclusively
can also help us identify the specific
positions
in the interaction between these two
proteins that could be
intervened in or that could be trained
for the human immune system to be able
to recognize
the specific binding positions and the
specific variation
that is typical in these types of
infections that we can start
designing vaccines and drugs
now let's take a look at another example
here's an example
of ebola virus and the ebola virus
is also very diverse and has
occurred in several different pandemics
that were observed
in the west africa region now in that
west africa region
we can take samples and by the way this
was one of the
the 2014 2016
[Music]
outbreaks uh was one of the first major
efforts
in near real time sequencing that
produced
thousands and thousands of samples that
we can analyze for diversity
now looking at that diversity we can
identify the most
prominent changes in the viral
sequences that were sampled and identify
which proteins are they accumulated
in so for example in this study you can
see
how again we have multiple reads
from many many samples from population
samples
those reads were aligned together into
the reference genome
as a result of the alignment we identify
specific positions
and those positions can reveal important
proteins
where such mutations can play a
functional role
that could be linked to virulence
transmission
and ultimately inform vaccine design
importantly we have today an antiviral
drug
and a vaccine for the ebola virus as a
result of bioinformatics and as a result
of such analyses
so having access to data and access to
tools that could be used
can help us identify specific changes
and ask the question of their
functional significance as well as what
type of information
could they reveal that is important for
drug and vaccine design but so far we've
talked a lot about
viruses what about other types of
pathogens
specifically bacterial pathogens like
tuberculosis
and such pathogens like malaria which
are actually
also developing drug resistance
so for those types of bacterial
infections and these types of
situations one of the similar approaches
can actually help us reveal
what genomic variation is responsible
for single antibiotic resistant or
multiple
antibiotic resistant types of pathogens
so here you can see specific mutations
that are associated
with different types of drugs where
resistance in tuberculosis is developed
now that is not done by looking at just
individual positions and multiple
sequence alignment if we return
to this platform interface we can see
that some additional important sections
are
available here to ask such questions of
genomic data
so for example here we have genome
wide association studies that
essentially
help us ask the question if i have a
defined phenotype
and that phenotype is resistance to a
particular drug let's say i know that a
drug
is being administered in this region in
this hospital for this patient
[Music]
how can i ask the question what is the
association
between the specific variation in the
genome of that pathogen
and what is the association with the
phenotype right so if the phenotype
sorry i'm trying to meet someone
okay there we go
so if i can find such an association
i can actually identify which mutation
is responsible for accumulation of drug
resistance
similarly i can have a more of an
approach of multi-omics integration
where i have an ability to ask the
question
how is a mutation specifically
responsible
for the interaction with the host so if
i have the host data
and i have the genomic data from my
viral or bacterial pathogen i can start
looking for
associations in such data sets that can
reveal
interaction between different proteins
and signaling pathways
and help me identify how to intervene
in those interactions
now importantly the examples that i'm
showing you are just
to get you thinking about what types of
analysis
what types of data and what types of
questions
you might have about a project that is
interesting to you
so these examples are based on some
publications that what we did is
we took the data from those publications
we looked at the methods that they used
and then we combined those together to
produce tutorials
that could be used as a starting point
for a research project now if you're a
student or you're just learning about
bioinformatics what you might want to do
is you might want to do some similar
analysis
and develop a novel and independent
project
and such a novel and independent project
can really give you a sense
of how such tools can be used for this
type of data
now as i mentioned such data is widely
available
one example that we can briefly look at
is on
ncbi virus
where a lot of this data is hosted and
is freely available
so i'm just going to go to ncbi virus
first and then i'll also show a couple
of examples from
the ncbi repository where you can look
at data sets
for other types of pathogens
so an ncbi virus you can start by
searching by sequence or
you can look by virus
so if all of you try this tool out what
you can easily do here is
enter for example ebola virus
you can just wait a couple of seconds
you can see that the ebola virus appears
right here and i can
access over 3000 sequences
from ebola virus and you can see that
they come from different locations
they come from different sources at
different time frames
so i can really start designing my
questions
around the data sets that are available
right here
let's go back and instead of ebola virus
let's uh look for coronavirus
so here you can see the whole corona
viridae and the coronaviridae
also comes from different hosts so
animal hosts as well as human hosts
and i can also narrow this
for different locations geographic
region
isolation source and dates so again the
same type of analysis that we went
through today
comparing different sequences and asking
what might those sequence analysis
results mean functionally you can also
conduct
just by taking data from here another
great repository
is for all other types of data where you
can also find
host response to coronavirus infection
you can find
malaria sequences tuberculosis sequences
ebola virus and other pathogenic
sequences as well as the host response
and you can really start looking
at both the diversity of these viral
populations the
microbiome that they uh that they
best develop in or worse developing and
also the response to different
treatments so here if you look for
coronavirus you will see that there's
of course a lot of different types of
data that you can find
including gene expression data
over 3 000 gene expression omnibus data
sets
you can see 351 bio projects
which in in each in all of these
projects together have
over 100 000 bio samples
so you really have a lot of access to
data sets right here
and over a hundred thousand sra
which is the sequence read archive or
the raw fast q file so really
a tremendous diversity of data sets if
you just look through some of the titles
of these bio projects
you can find what type of data sets are
available
and think how can you ask a specific
question of these data sets for example
evaluating the microbial context of
source code 2 in patients and the
hospital-built environment
or super spreading events preceding a
large meat processing plant related
source coronavirus two outbreak in
germany
right so really fascinating data sets
many of these data sets
have a publication associated with it
and some of them don't because they're
very new
so you can see that this was submitted
on the 3rd of november so just recently
there's not even a publication
associated with this data set
and you can easily access over 1 000
samples here
to start asking questions well what is
really going on and how can i ask this
question
based on the data that i have available
so i think that this represents a huge
opportunity
to design and develop novel types of
projects
that you can start using some of the
tools
and the data sets that we have discussed
today
now i also want to tell you a little bit
about
the training that our company provides
to help you get
started using some of the tools and the
methods that we discussed
we run a series of onyx logic training
programs
that are intended to provide
bioinformatics guidance
for independent research using
bioinformatics
with assistance from mentors and peer
example
and our goal is to develop a community
that has data-driven research interest
and an appreciation of citizen science
and
we want to make sure that students
clinicians faculty of all backgrounds
are able to apply bioinformatics
effectively
to these kinds of questions and so
thinking about the interest
and the available resources for
infectious diseases we've designed
this novel program called bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
this program will help you understand
pathogens
and the diseases that they cause by
analyzing data
and learn about the different analysis
approaches that can help
detect viral genomes in next-generation
sequencing data
to ask questions about how these
sequences are different
and apply those types of analyses to
different types of
functional and important projects like
vaccine design
antiviral drug design antibiotic
resistance
epidemiology and others
what we provide in the context of this
project of this program
are curated projects and data sets just
like what we discussed today very
briefly
in this program we will go through in
much greater detail
and so we'll talk about different types
of viruses like coronaviruses and also
different types of bacterial pathogens
as well
the programs are really combined out of
several different elements they
include online sessions like today
we try to make them interactive and
they're conducted by multiple
uh guides that we have in our program
they also have access to self-guided
study materials that you can access
independently
and some practical assignments so let me
briefly show you what those look like
so the platform that we already talked
about
is one of these resources this resource
allows you to
analyze publicly available data sets
easily with a user interface
we also have a number of projects that
you can use to get started with your
research project or analyze data from
other types of data sets and we have
coding exercises and i'll just briefly
show you one of these coding exercises
that is
very basic but introduces you into
coding practices using r and python
to analyze genomic sequences so here you
can see
a breakdown of the code you can then
learn about
more advanced variation of the analysis
including pairwise analysis and multiple
sequence alignment
and importantly you get these
assignments where you have to modify the
code
and run it to produce a result now all
of this
interaction with the coding assignments
with
uh running individual pipelines or even
completing some of the lessons
and projects that you will see right
here all of this
becomes available under your individual
profile and so you get to build up a
profile
of your own to demonstrate what types of
skills
you have achieved by participating in
the program
and also develop an independent project
and we have a number of examples
that you can also look on our website to
see what students have been able to
develop as a result of
participating in a project like this in
a program like this
so to summarize uh the program will
start on
november 9th it is called bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
and it is a training program a
bioinformatics training program
that will help you explore relevant
tools methods and data repositories
learn from curated case studies and
peer-reviewed publications
test your understanding by analyzing
sample data
master key elements of analysis and
visualization
as well as design and develop an
independent research project
so these are some of the key topics that
we will cover
in this program and this program will
start
on november 9th now importantly
we have a place where you can find all
of these
details uh called bioinformatics
for infectious diseases and i'm just
going to paste
the link in the chat as well
on here you will find the details
including a brief
overview of the program the schedule of
the program
so we will have these different sessions
together
in each one you will find a description
of what topic will be covered
what is included in the program
registration
some of the comments some of the access
to some of the
resources that you will have some of the
projects
and some of the tools that we mentioned
and of course these sessions are
just one example of the types of
projects are the programs that we run
so you're welcome to explore some of the
additional programs that we have
available here as well
okay so thank you again for joining to
today
for this brief presentation um i am
happy to answer
any questions now that you might have
about
what we talked about today uh including
the program
and including some of the topics that we
discussed and the project examples that
we discussed
so if you have any question you're
welcome to
write it in the chat and i will answer
those